bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café una emisión producida por la
sección en español del difusor público
radio canadá internacional difundimos en
directo cada viernes a las dos y cuarto
por las redes sociales en internet
en esta emisión les presentamos los
temas destacados de la semana y
compartimos los mensajes enviados por
correo electrónico este programa también
se encuentra disponible en nuestro sitio
en internet r design & punto sea si
quieren escribir nos pueden hacerlo a la
dirección electrónica amlat
r design & punto o sea hoy les acompañan
en los micrófonos paloma martín
leonora chapman leonardo gimeno y
quienes salva ruso valencia en la
versión radio de este programa
disponible en nuestro sitio eres mi
punto o sea les presentaremos la música
de artistas canadienses como detrás del
eje de taiji clip con el tema de lo de
haidar
recordando justamente el primer
aniversario de la muerte del cantante de
ese grupo cordón y fallecido el 17 de
octubre de 2017 a los 53 años también
escucharemos a la gran cantante de
alberta casting down down by the land
con uno de sus éxitos constant trevín
ese o constante de su álbum ingenio
grabado de 1991
hablando de presidente
con la música últimamente ruffo
porque hablando de presidentes por
ejemplo hay un grupo mexicano los
embolados que en una canción que se
llama señor presidente que es una
canción de respuesta a las declaraciones
sobre los mexicanos y esas declaraciones
y ya sabemos de quién que cruza la
frontera y justamente y viendo en
historia de los archivos de la música
canadiense escucharemos a una de las
primeras estrellas de quebec la cantante
anna maria moix
1894 black conocida en escena como la
bolduc con el tema de mar en wine y la
letra dice el corrido tratado de escapar
de estos mosquitos que me atacan con sus
lanchas igual ahora con mosquitos
estamos hablando de 1824
no me molestó pero es un francés era en
inglés es una canción en inglés primero
si puedes ser capaz que eran francés y
muchas mucho de la música del rock
latinoamericano era justamente versiones
de las canciones en inglés estaban por
ejemplo el dúo dinámico en españa que
copiaba canciones del rock en inglés
chantal me confirma que sí y después se
popularizó en inglés y en español así
decir y rock en américa latina empieza
justamente cantando en inglés porque no
les parecía que el rock debe de ser
cantado en español hasta que surgieron
unos grupos extraordinarios
por dios y llenan estadios feroces los
tres en méxico y en argentina también y
en bolivia en todos los países
sí bueno quizás exploremos esa música en
los próximos programas bien empezamos
entonces el programa con las noticias
que les han llamado la atención por
a mí me llamó la atención el cambio de
deporte de cambio de deportes y una vez
lo intentó michael jordan no le salió se
pasó el básquet cuando dejó de jugar el
básquet fue a jugar al béisbol en las
ligas mayores no funcionó no jugó como
corresponde no se pudo mantener y ahora
usain bolt el velocista si se lleva 7 se
fue jugar al fútbol o sea australia
australia australia e hizo dos goles
ayer hacen su primer partido oficial
hizo dos goles uno de ellos un golazo el
segundo fue así medio como la realidad
porque no debe ser fácil no pero para
tirar un centro y que vaya él corriendo
a buscarlo
debe ser muy efectivo claro ya no hay
ese tipo de trayectoria deportiva en
américa latina que yo sepa bueno acá sí
acá hay una gran campeona olímpica de
juegos de verano y de invierno y era la
bicicleta era una en el verano y en el
invierno a los esquíes y ganó el sí yo
no sé si ganó el oro con la bicicleta
pero ganó una medalla pero lo que cierto
es que dicen que son deportes que son
semejantes al movimiento que tiene que
ser con las piernas particularmente en
la bicicleta y en el esquí de fondo es
semejante pero el bueno también se coló
mucho en el fútbol hierro existencia
física sí pero hay distintos tipos de
movimientos no hace carreras 100 metros
o de los 400 metros son lo hace en línea
recta o de la curva que tiene el estadio
digamos pero el ejercicio es muy
particular en el fútbol hay
desplazamientos de costado
desplazamiento para atrás
o sea no es lo mismo lo que el esquí
tampoco en la bicicleta no que el esquí
también perdón también te desplazas en
un momento dado pero en el esquí de
fondo es más derecho
en el esquí de fondo si fuera el pinos y
al desplazamiento de costado por ejemplo
juego dos deportes en el invierno jugar
al voley y en el verano juego al fútbol
y me duelen
tenía cuando era joven me gustaba
muchísimo el basket y la pelota al cesto
y fuimos campeones me acuerdo hace mucho
en el secundario
a nivel nacional con la pelota
la pelota rebota la pelota al sexto
la tienes no puedes correr con la pelota
solo tienes que hacer tres movimientos
tres pasos con la pelota y estás
obligado a tirarla cuando te mueves
y hay 12 porque son los palos y el sexto
y no tiene donde chocarán de hacer
realmente es muy británico ni escuela
nosotros en los pueblos los campeonatos
interescolares nosotros jugamos al
fútbol voley al básquet y las chicas
sobre todo jugadores de las muchas
muchas pelotas el sexto las chicas
siempre tras esto y asia
el sóftbol que es como el béisbol pero
con el bate más grueso la pelota más
grande a distintos tipos movimiento el
pitcher no desde arriba sino desde abajo
y ahí tú paloma practique muchísimos
años la natación competitiva
y ahora pues hago bicicleta y me encanta
la bicicleta la marcha
deporte favorito es ver caer por la
ventana comiendo algo seguro a mí me da
leer nieve director técnico mío es mi
entrenador es mi perro a la mañana de la
noche porque no hay tiempo y además hay
otra gente que sale temprano y más lo
mismo tiene que hablar con la gente y
preferiría cambiar solo
[Risas]
muy bien luego que termine el ermitaño
y ahora que me llamo desagradablemente
la impresión en esta campaña electoral o
en brasil lo digo de esta manera porque
es un no me esperaba honestamente no
esperaba que con todo lo que está
pasando en el mundo con un presidente
que tenemos aquí en eeuu que a todo el
mundo lo conoce y que surja un candidato
que hasta la cándida a la aladi la líder
del partido de extrema derecha de
francia el de pan marino lohan dijo que
se distanció se distanció del candidato
de la extrema derecha de brasil que sé
bolsonaro se distanció de las
declaraciones y dijo para nada a ellos
no son anti feministas y no sé qué otra
cosa más dijo dijo no con eso nada que
ver porque aparte de este hombre
revolucionario se encargó de marcar la
diferencia con el resto del universo
diciendo las barrabasadas que dijo ese
es realmente la extrema derecha a mí me
da miedo me da
y solo pensar que un partido pro militar
pro golpe de estado anti derechos
humanos pueda llegar y pro tortura y que
vuelva a llegar a la presidencia de
brasil el país más grande y más poderoso
de américa latina y uno de los cinco
países emergentes más poderoso del
planeta me da bastante miedo y el tema
es que ganó por bastante y lo que es de
lo que es peor dentro de todo gesto
contra el candidato hay que reconocer
que aquí están pasando cosas en brasil
que no pasan normalmente en un país
normal bueno el hecho de que se haya
impedido que lula se presentará como
candidato a último momento se presenta
el candidato a sadat que hay que decir
que hizo una buena campaña en el poquito
lapso de tiempo que le quedó es decir él
obtuvo 22 en 20 días obtuvo el 39 por
ciento contra el 40 y 46 47 del otro
candidato
yo entiendo la historia de que la gente
necesita un cambio la alternancia
política y tal pero si puede ser tan
ciego para no ver que este hombre va ni
siquiera se le puede llamar hombre
egoísta
yo creo que hay que respetar también hay
gente que cree que tiene esos valores y
eso es no sabemos por qué pero si tanta
gente está votando por él hay algo que
está haciendo este candidato yo creo que
lo que está lo que está jugando
muchísimo acá al igual que en otros
países son los medios de comunicación
hay que decir que este señor tiene el
apoyo total completo de este gran
movimiento religioso que son los
evangelistas que controlan gran parte de
los medios también en brasil también
está apoyado por los medios de derecha
económicamente hablando entonces lo que
yo leí un poco y eso me llamó la
atención fue una campaña feroz que
desataron estos medios una semana antes
de la votación en la cual acusaban al
candidato
y vi penetraron en las favelas y
penetraron en todo porque estos este
grupo religioso tiene entrada a todos
los lugares también donde lo fue feroz
contra haddad donde decían por ejemplo
de que el tipo del candidato haddad
quería por ejemplo el que que los que
los pervertir a los niños en las
escuelas primarias en la cuestión de
sexo y le decían a la gente si usted
tiene una hija así se llama maria bueno
él quiere que se llame mario a partir de
que si es elegido una serie de cosas
para nosotros inadmisibles pero para la
gente estaban muy bien hecha esa campaña
electoral hacia ese nivel pues lo
perjudicaba desinforma totalmente y
entonces eso en parte juega pues un
papel importante y otro otro factor que
lo que lo dijo el ex presidente de
uruguay pepe mujica y que yo sí veo ahí
también una una entrada de que es para
comprender lo que está pasando no sólo
en brasil es que es verdad es decía que
él lula sacó a 40 millones de brasil
de la extrema pobreza con encima extrema
pobreza es que ya no tienes casi ni para
comer lo saco con programas sociales y
políticos específicos ahora cuando uno
va y le pregunta a la gente está bien
estás mejor estabas mejor sí porque
estabas mejor gracias a ello yo fui
capaz de salir de esto individualmente
el mito de que no hay una percepción de
que hay políticas que se implementaron
para que se produzcan esos cambios y
entonces lo que dice pepe mujica es sean
sean han sacado de la miseria 40
millones ahora pueden comercial con se
han convertido en consumidores pero no
en ciudadanos es decir no con no son
conscientes políticamente de quienes
aportaron esos cambios y
yo hablaba esto creo que con paloma ayer
también por ejemplo hicieron vilma
lalalala bla bla mauser rousseff mandó a
hacer una en una encuesta entre las
mujeres antes de ser destituida a ella
y preguntando a las mujeres y ambiente
cómo había mejorado su vida cuando
estuvo el pp gobernando brasil no
entonces una amplia mayoría dice que
había mejorado muchísimo cuando le
preguntaban cuál era la causa porque
había mejorado y dijeron gracias a dios
entonces volvemos a lo mismo lo que
decía pepe mujica es que no se han
creado no vendieron bien no supieron ir
a concientizar si quieres políticamente
y crear ciudadanos capaces de darse
cuenta de que son gracias a las
políticas que pudieron salir de eso
están son consumidores sí y esos
consumidores están escuchándolo hoy a
este candidato de extrema derecha que
les promete el oro y el moro no claro
entonces hay por ahí por ello creo que
pasa un poco también pero no explica
todo tampoco la respuesta promete te
dije con sus políticas de seguridad de
que la policía debe directamente
dispararse bueno el vehículo policía que
no mata no es policía no es un buen
policía y lo dijo públicamente y no
vamos a repetir las cosas que dijo
porque creo que no hace mucho con
escuché tantas barbaridad
de un personaje público candidato a
presidente entonces eso fue lo que me
sorprendió y me sorprende aún más hoy
saber que cuenta con el 55% del apoyo en
según las encuestas en las elecciones
que va a haber en dos semanas que es el
28 de octubre sin bueno entonces saloma
bueno a mí lo que me llamó la atención
hago muchos temas que me preocuparon
durante la semana pero me llamó la
atención otro buque es una cosa muy
simpática en realidad es la ceremonia de
ciudadanía que tuvo lugar en la torre cn
hubo frontón en toronto el ministro de
la ciudadanía de inmigración de canadá
es un refugiado que es un refugiado
ausentes y ahmed husein e hizo esta
ceremonia a seis personas a seis nuevos
canadienses pero esta gente los
chistosos que estaban amarrados ves que
hay una zona en la en la torre centramos
la foto sino que en la que la gente se
puede amarrar con un arnés
y en la orillita de la torre
prestaron juramento a la ciudadanía
canadiense con él y con el ministro
también guardamos un ministro para
mostrar a todos entonces bueno me
parecía simpático y bueno nada más
recordarle a la gente que canadá el año
pasado recibió 270 mil inmigrantes y que
bueno para hacer y mí para hacer
ciudadano para después de ser
inmigrantes pues éste de ser residente
permanente bueno hay que uno solicitar
ser ciudadano y bueno es ahí explicamos
en el reportaje que en el artículo que
escribí sobre los detalles para obtener
la ciudadanía canadiense pero me pareció
gracioso entonces entre todas las cosas
feas que han sucedido durante las tropas
dije bueno dando la bien si además que
justamente este viernes concluye la
semana de la ciudadanía
es verdad
y no empezaba la semana de la hispanidad
en canadá mes de la hispanidad
en toronto solamente voluntario no pero
el sena del senado canadiense determinó
que octubre es el mes de la herencia
latinoamericana en canadá la es la
senadora independiente rosa gálvez que
hizo que lanzó para que retome que
retomó digamos 11
un proyecto de ley de un senador de
origen filipino era el que había traído
la idea de tener un mes del patrimonio
latinoamericano en canadá él murió en
colombia por azares del destino
rosa gálvez la senadora retomo él
en algún momento también hablamos con
ella cuando se aprobó este este mes de
la nación americana si conversé con ella
también entonces si es una persona
interesantísima
entonces ella fue la que llevó este este
proyecto de ley que fue aprobado y este
es el mes de la interamericana
en toronto le llama en el mes de la
hispanidad y hay mucha controversia
ese es el tema aquí que miraba atención
justamente estamos a 526 años no sé a
qué hora llegó el barco del genocidio
tuve dos días y 526 años y ahí este
injustamente trágicamente y digo
trágicamente coincide con una decisión
de la corte suprema de canadá que
determinó hace un día o dos
que los ministros de que el gobierno no
necesita
consulta a las primeras naciones sobre
proyectos de económicos del desarrollo
económico lo cual a primera vista
batasunas granados con tratados ya
firmados o no firmados pero tratados que
hicieron las primeras naciones con la
época colonial con inglaterra y con
francis de igual a igual y justamente
esto en momentos en que hay puesto de
ésta
y esto para de irnos a primera vista va
va en contra de él va en contra de la
declaración de naciones unidas sobre los
derechos de los pueblos indígenas que
llama justamente que tiene que haber
hecho un derecho es de hecho información
y tomar decisiones bien informados y un
líder indígena decía bueno tiene que
entender el gobierno de que tenemos el
derecho de decir no sobre qué es lo que
va a pasar sobre nuestros territorios
entonces donde una fue una fue una
votación dividida a 7 a 22 son dos
mujeres las que votaron en contra
y justamente decían de que no que ya
llegó el momento que esto va un poco
contra también la famosa etapa de
reconciliación entre las primeras
naciones y el gobierno canadiense porque
es una como un golpe nuevamente y sobre
todo una de estas juezas dijo de que era
consideraba que era importante que
cuando les concernía en estos temas a
las primeras naciones tenían que ser
consultado
ellos dicen que eso no existe en canadá
ni en ningún país del mundo donde haya
una legislación que sea discutida antes
de ser aprobada lo que ellos dicen es
que es una legislación que está a la
corte suprema o las cortes que aprueban
y a partir de ese momento cuando se crea
esa ley si naciones están en desacuerdo
en algún punto se entra a discutir eso
fue un poco los grandes argumentos no lo
que sí lo que dijeron es el doble esta
primera nación que es de la provincia de
alberta y que llegó a la corte suprema
el caso dijo ahora que van a ir a las
instancias internacionales como naciones
unidas entre otros organismos justamente
porque él dice decía de que gracias a la
presión que ejercieron las primeras
naciones a contra o con el gobierno ante
el gobierno
canadiense han logrado que canadá firme
esta convención de los derechos
indígenas en naciones unidas que durante
muchos años
canadá no había firmado y entonces en
dentro de esa convención está
contemplado parece ese tema
entonces bueno van a continuar este es
un clima que no se acaba con esta
decisión de la corte suprema-
sorprendente carlos las primeras
naciones canadienses son las naciones
fundadoras de este país son broten sólo
tú son quienes exactamente la a quienes
estaban aquí antes de que llegaran los
franceses los británicos etcétera
nosotros antes de que todo el mundo
pero es decir mes me sorprende mucho
esta decisión de la corte suprema y me
sorprende también que aunque se haya
sido dividida la decisión es tan
dividida y hay una cuestión de legal que
yo no la entiendo totalmente es decir
una cosa es
el problema político y otra cosa es las
leyes y el problema legal entonces ahí
es donde yo no lo tengo todavía muy
claro y bueno esta es una cuestión que
analizó la corte suprema y ellos son
expertos también en este tema entonces
pues habría que investigar un poco más
porque si crea precedentes como decía
así no hay otras cosas
lo creas residentes cuando en realidad
se le está dando lugar a un pueblo que
en realidad es el propietario de la
tierra claro sí y justamente esto
refleja también esta pone de nuevo sobre
la mesa esta tendencia que entre las
naciones indignas entre los jóvenes
porque hay dos tendencias una que es la
reconciliación pero los jóvenes hablan
no de reconciliación sino de resistencia
los jóvenes lógicamente los jóvenes que
toman la palabra
probablemente indígena
eso es en todo el mundo los jóvenes
tienen esa necesidad de lucha después
cuando uno va creciendo se le van a
pagar con la reconciliación
conciliación pero con la verdadera
reconciliación donde se contemplen las
las los intereses de cada grupo que está
ahí en pugna y sería una verdadera yo sé
que él es el primer ministro que a nadie
en serio centro do no tiene ninguna
incidencia en las decisiones de la corte
suprema de justicia canadiense en uno
latín sin embargo si es su gobierno se
presentó desde el principio como el
gobierno de la reconciliación con los
pueblos indígenas todo por eso esto que
es todavía más sorprenden sorprendente
que sea dentro de su mandato y esto
suceda pero ya lo dijiste no tiene nada
que más no tiene nada que ver acá los
poderes están separados sí sí por suerte
sorprendente por suerte sino como eeuu
sí entonces planteamos la pregunta a
nuestros oyentes en el sitio internet
justamente como que se si qué significa
este 2 de octubre en sus países sin su
cultura para ellos mismos es que todavía
significa algo históricamente digo el 12
de octubre en américa latina porque yo
se festeja para nada
la noción misma del descubrimiento de la
yo creo que es hoy el día de la raza en
méxico le dicen el día de la raza
yo creo que ya no tiene el mismo sentido
no tiene otro sentido
ahí tenemos algunos algunos oyentes que
están en línea conocí tenemos aquí en
miguel rovira que está dice escribe algo
en la página en realidad es hora antes
de que empezara cuando estará nuestro
cartelito que dice que se viene la
transmisión carlos tapia dice atento a
que empiece también antes de empezar a
transmisiones y alexander hernández y
saludos desde bogotá colombia si quiera
que no hablas o todos ellos si estaba
poniendo i rovira es de de españa no sé
si lo hicimos español y no lo es le
perdimos le pedimos disculpas y que nos
explique dónde está que nos cuente en
qué parte de américa latina o del mundo
se encuentra él
y que nos explica que pienses o qué
piensa él también sobre este día el 12
de octubre a que efectivamente quienes
están escuchando que nada las américas
es café el programa de fin de semana de
radio canadá internacional vamos a dar
lectura a algunas de las cartas que
hemos recibido no sé si no te va muy
bien con lo que estamos hablando español
en canadá una nueva ventana para ver el
mundo a ver dice eduardo gutiérrez hola
buenas tardes les saluda eduardo
gutiérrez de tax a la plata que a dar la
escala la escala mexico pues estoy
contento que el idioma español se hable
en montreal en julio pasado que estuve
en montreal platicaba a unas personas
que montreal es la ciudad que más se
habla español y si de verdad en toronto
como quebec
me costaba comunicarme después de poco
inglés y menos aún francés pero aprendí
mucho saludos a la sociedad canadiense
ya estoy estudiando francés
eduardo gutiérrez buenas que comentamos
esta semana leonora información
leonora y yo con respecto a la
proporción de latinoamérica
en toronto y en montreal y
proporcionalmente ahí
en cantidad hay más latinoamericanos en
toronto pero proporcionalmente hay más
latinoamericanos en montreal que en
toronto
es interesante entonces tiene razón de
decir que se habla mucho español en
montreal y así corazón cualquiera y un
mejor servicios que fue al centro de la
ciudad los centros comerciales escuchaba
salsas merengues yo creo que una persona
hoy puede vivir en español dijo una por
ejemplo me refiero específicamente a
gente de américa latina que trae a los
abuelos por ejemplo acá a vivir porque
ya no tienen nada que hacer en sus
países los hijos se vinieron todos para
acá y me acuerdo haberme encontrado con
una familia colombiana cuyo hijo que es
grande ya decía la traje a mi mamá y
está feliz acá y tiene amigas de todos
lados de américa latina
vive en español va al hacer las compras
en español toma el autobús todo se
maneja en español y si yo tengo dos
anécdotas una apenas llegué conocí a una
persona
un peruano que hacía 30 años que vive en
canadá no tenía en la ciudad su
ciudadanía canadiense y no hablaba ni
francés ni inglés yo le pregunté cómo
hace para vivir eso yo veo un barrio
donde somos dos latinos y bueno como
compras
en los negocios el negocio latino del
esquí de micas y como hablan en la
escuela cuando van tu hijo a la escuela
hay una de las celadoras que habla habla
español y uno de los profesores le
encanta el español habla con un acento
importante pero habla español así que
evidentemente hay lugares donde uno
puede vivir en español sin necesidad de
hablarlo trabajar así por ejemplo
compañías que eso es era mera muy común
entre los latinoamericanos compañías de
limpieza por ejemplo de edificios que el
gerente o el dueño de esa empresa
llegaba a ser un latinoamericano que
contrataba a latinoamericanos era un
medio muy latinoamericano y la otros
restaurante y la otra anécdota es yo
paseando con mi familia por el centro de
montreal en un día festivo y había una
evidentemente una familia de turistas
con su
desplegado su mapa para ver dónde están
parados qué lástima que en este lugar
nadie habla español y yo me doy vuelta
leo se habla hay mucha gente que el
español misa y usted desde hace una
semana que estamos la primera persona
que nos habla en español el ibex pero es
bonito y levante la mano empecé hay
alguien que habla español hay alguien
vuelve a nuestros cinco familias
pregunta
así que me ocurre también que no sé si
nos ha pasado que se encuentran con
otros norteamericanos ustedes saben que
eso no tiene mexicanos pero continúan
hablando en inglés entonces a veces
depende de la generación no de
generaciones hay un hay jóvenes de
origen latinoamericano que a lo mejor no
puedo hablar
obviamente ya no te das cuenta que les
gustas hablando hable si son jóvenes han
nacido acá se han criado acá la lengua
de ellos es francés inglés y
posiblemente tercero español siguen
igualmente tiene hay mucha mucha de la
mezcla también sobre todo en los socios
y cosas en el switch más rápidamente
nosotros venimos hablando así porque
estuvo en el control del del banco y
cuando salí me encontré cinco de la
destinación el tatuaje y uno mezcla
palabras en inglés y en francés mientras
habla pero como sabe que el que está
aquí lo entiende y nos informe
gente nunca va a trabajar en naciones
unidas por ejemplo y es un mensaje si
vamos bueno dice es para hay bueno no me
he dado cuenta pero es un reportaje que
yo hice que es como una lingüista
argentina es hoy especialista de una
lengua indígena canadiense es una
entrevista que hice yo con jimena
terraza una justamente lingüista
argentina que trabaja aquí que presentó
un libro sobre la lengua mus mucho no de
mucho pero se llama mus cri-cri de mus
es la lengua
del alce pero pero se llama mucho
músculo y en en inglés luego dice bueno
a todo el personal del sainete muchas
gracias en lo cual he difundido a mi
querida añoranza art añoranza argentina
buenos aires del partido francés una
palabra tan argentina hay una samba que
se titula añoranza que es una belleza
entonces y escuchas le digo a esta
argentina si no llega otra samba es la
mayor algias
se habla de jugar desde un lugar un
pueblito particularmente donde pasan
todas catástrofes es más llama añoranzas
en honor al jazz la samba catástrofe
bueno entonces no sé en qué contexto nos
dice a mi querida y añoranza argentina a
porque habla de argentino del país o sea
mi querido argentina que el año oro ok
me falta el extraño pueden ir un tango
por las venas si dice se están enterando
de la realidad de autor contario toronto
y el granca nada aparte de mi vecindad
hice a través de ese y llamada park de
él a la distancia en toronto central les
saludó fraternalmente patricia yancovich
activista y luchadora social desde allá
desde toronto
gracias.patricia yo aquí tengo otro
mensaje en este caso sobre la historia
del baile y la rueda de casino salsa o
qué complicado que es el nuestro sí pero
william y giles dice el reportaje hay
gente que cuando le pregunto qué baila
meses yo bailo cubano entonces le
preguntó pero cual cubano
son mambo cha cha cha cha pachanga
guajira guaguancó
william hill se dice para esta gente a
bailar con únicamente significa bailar
casino generalmente con la música que se
llama timba claro que todos estos bailes
que menciono son cubanos de origen
cubano y que se siguen bailando hoy en
todas partes del mundo es lindo bailar
casino pero es sólo uno de los muchos
bailes cubanos que se bailan hoy y salsa
es un término un término de marketing
creo que nació en eeuu dice williams
que encubre a todos estos bailes al
punto que los nombres verdaderos de los
bailes cubanos se han olvidado la salsa
en sí no existe latitud puente siempre
decía que lo que tocaban una salsa y que
la salsa es lo que le ponía a las papas
fritas lo cierto es que los únicos que
bailan la rueda de casino son los
cubanos los únicos que pueden
colombianas nunca nos complican o no
es muy difícil yo no veo lo hacen como
si fuera cualquier casinos en lugar de
apostar entre varios y dan vueltas así
como si nada
nuestra ex colega sevilla bailaba muy
bien vamos ahora acelerando el programa
que nos quedan a 11 minutos para
presentarles a nuestros oyentes así pues
lástima bolsonaro etcétera etcétera en
tu paloma nos hablas de los trabajadores
agrícolas mexicanos que una vez más
sensible a ningún 100 sus condiciones de
trabajo
exactamente sonante es un reportaje que
originalmente realizaron unos
periodistas en ontario en la región de
lymington que es considerada la capital
del tomate en canadá entonces éste les
podemos poner las imágenes leonardo
ellos fueron encontrar a tres
trabajadores mexicanos que denunciaron
particularmente
las condiciones con respecto al uso de
pesticidas en las en los invernaderos
donde trabajan lo que contaban es que
ellos los dueños de las granjas los
dueños de los inviernos y fumigan los
los invernaderos como tal dentro del
invernadero tres veces por semana y
muchas veces vienen los que vienen a
fumigar vienen protegidos con máscaras
de gas y vienen con todos mientras que
los trabajadores mexicanos participando
en este programa de trabajadores
agrícolas temporales están dentro de los
invernaderos recolectan cosechando el
tomate y no están protegidos mientras
están siendo fumigados junto con las
plantas de trabajo que extraño que no
haya una reacción a eso de salud de
ontario o de algún organismo bueno en lo
que ellos denunciaron fue eso y entonces
los reportes claro entonces el
ministerio de desarrollo social creo que
es eviten que hagan este programa en
particular reaccionó al reportaje de
radio canadá entonces
diseñaron inspectores o algo muy ágil
hablaron de las multas que van a ser
impuestas si se descubre si se prueba
esto que los trabajadores están diciendo
otros trabajadores eran tres
trabajadores del uno de ellos tuvo
una piedra en la vesícula piedra en él
muchas gracias y él explicó que lo
tuvieron que operar y al salir del
hospital el su jefe le pidió que
volviera inmediatamente al trabajo y
claro que no podía no le daban por lo
menos una semana más
de incapacidad entonces él le dijo tengo
que quedarme una semana más en cama y el
dueño de la granja le dijo bueno pues te
vuelves a méxico y le compró un boleto
para volver a méxico un boleto de avión
bueno son tres casos no quiere decir que
todos los casos de trabajadores
agrícolas temporales en canadá sean así
lo cierto es que la región de lymington
en ontario recibe alrededor de 55 mil
trabajadores anualmente durante periodos
de que van entre 6 y 8 meses entonces
bueno esto sí estos reporteros con los
que yo estuve en comunicación en de
radio canadá entonces en ontario me
enviaron las imágenes y armamos un
pequeño reportaje a partir de las
imágenes y las entrevistas en español
que hicieron con estos trabajadores
entonces ese es el reporte ciento esta
semana
leonora tú no se presenta es un gran
personaje de la política canadiense
frank quien sí y yo como lo dices es un
gran personaje yo lo considero uno de
los primeros ministros más importantes
que tuvo canadá no sólo porque gobernó
fue electo tres veces primer ministro de
canadá y además mayoría los tres
gobiernos sino que durante uno de esos
gobiernos lo que a mí siempre me queda
grabado y sobre todo en estos tiempos
tan aciagos así hago algo
en estos tiempos tan aciagos pues
recuerdo perfectamente cuando fue cuando
eeuu se dispuso a atacar irak con esta
famosa mentira fíjate a los medios en
aquel entonces como fabricaban las
noticias falsas
falsificaron que sadam husein tenía un
arsenal de bombas nucleares y lo que
fuera más claro de destrucción masiva y
que hasta último minuto sufrió jan
christian la presión del que era en ese
momento el presidente de eeuu bush hijo
sirve el cabo los dos eran cabo en el
bar el viejo éste sufrieron la presión
tremenda de eeuu de que jean chrétien yo
me acuerdo perfectamente para que
participara de esta misión en de ataque
a irak y ya que dijo que mientras no
fuera una misión aprobada por naciones
unidas en el contexto en general el
mundo declaró multilateral en el canadá
no iba a participar y se mantuvo y no lo
hizo
entonces la noticia ahora es que él
acaba de estar publicando está saliendo
su libro ahora en inglés se llama mis
mis tiempos algo así espérate que me
acuerde bien bueno ya me va a salir unas
historias mis tiempos y fue hubo una una
entrevista además de una hora que tuvo
en el radiodifusor públicos y vice tuvo
otro con la prensa canadiense en team
todo el mundo pero en vez de preguntarle
sobre el libro estos periodistas
aprovechan la oportunidad que el crimen
al frente a jan christian y le hacen
preguntas de la política canadiense de
política internacional qué momento él
dijo pregunta el mes sobre el libro
vender libros hay que decir que a él le
encanta ha visto a hablar porque tiene
además una una coherencia en su en su
manera de ser de pensar y de actuar
curiosos realistas los precios decían
que se mantiene muy alta tiene 84 años
es una lucidez que ojalá la tuvieran
mucho está trabajando
así que trabajando todos los días va a
su estudio de abogados y la mujer dice
pues si la casa del primer ministro de
ella salió al frente y bueno sin
desmerecerlo a él pero fue ella la que
lo detuvo el tipo más duro dice unas
mujeres que él está muy cansado el
primer ministro tenía que dormir se
dormía más fácilmente
el tema es que habló de todo como
siempre y lo la entrevista fue un día
después de las declaraciones de trump
cuando se había burlado de esta mujer
que fue asaltada sexualmente dice ella
por este juez que fue nombrado a la
corte suprema y hubo una escena donde
realmente se ve a trump que se burla de
ella y entonces ahí él dice dijo no me
sentiría orgulloso si mi primer ministro
hubiera hecho algo así ya está poniendo
oposición directamente no sobre lado lo
que es canadá y lo que es eeuu y también
lo interesante anda de muchas cosas ahí
están el reportaje no tenemos tiempo de
comentar todo hablo
supremacistas blancos quizá ahí se ve
dice el ver la verdadera naturaleza de
trump explica por qué hablo del tratado
de libre comercio norteamericano este ex
acaba de negocio dijo wow es lo mismo de
siempre para eso tanto tanto descalabro
durante 14 meses y tiene razón y
entonces lo que también en este en este
libro lo que él se le preguntó mucho
también fue sobre el sistema de justicia
en canadá que él dice que está a salvo
de la politización a diferencia de eeuu
entonces hay mucho para aquí para leer y
para ver en este reportaje
jan christian sigue siendo jean chrétien
y lo interesante también habló en un
momento dado y puse un videito ahí como
para que los que entienden inglés pero
por lo menos está transcrito donde el
habla de que esto el hecho dice el
ascenso de trump anuncia el declive del
imperio americano y lo dice porque es
muy bueno muy muy bueno y ustedes
hicieron reportajes o esta semana yo
quería decir que manfred sería guionista
que voy conmemoramos el día de la
culturalidad y la plurinacionalidad
conociendo la influencia de promover el
diálogo entre culturas y fortalecer a la
unidad nacional 2 de octubre día de la
interculturalidad en ecuador está eso
está interesante y tú leonardo nos habla
de un científico que ha grabado toda su
vida en realidad empezó hace un par de
años y lo sigue haciendo y dice que lo
va a hacer hasta su muerte y tiene que
ver con un proyecto del imade del
massachusetts institute of technology
en realidad nace todo de la vida
personal de este muchacho que se hace
llamar niño como el de matrix
y él tenía sus dos abuelas con alzheimer
entonces se puso a investigar sobre la
pérdida de la memoria y el significado
de la memoria en el ser humano y
entonces ha inventado en realidad por
ahora es un prototipo un casco con el
casco va grabando todo lo que pasa a
nivel cerebral y él
tiene una cámara que va grabando todo lo
que él hace entonces él después hace un
compendio del día analizando las
reacciones de su cerebro cosa extra la
sala along a su vivencia cuando va a
guardar como evidentemente él es un
investigador si se está haciendo una
prueba para ver si pueden armar algún
dispositivo para ayudar a la gente que
pierde memoria yo haciendo una lectura
quizás entre líneas está haciéndolo para
él porque si tiene las dos abuelas con
alzheimer probablemente él
entonces sí pero toda la gente que puede
desarrollar finalmente y yo les
recomiendo una entrevista con el
profesor giuseppe coco en hecho en río
de janeiro
él es un analista político que estuvo
aquí en montreal y él justamente explica
por qué la gente votó por ser bolsonaro
y dice básicamente que la gente no cree
en los partidos políticos y que ésta
está hasta el cuello con la violencia la
inseguridad y que y que no hay otra
forma no hay otras formas de eligen a un
violento eligen digamos fuego contra el
fuego
bien amigos entonces aquí llegamos al
final de nuestro programa estuvieron hoy
con ustedes paloma martínez eleonora
chapman leonardo gimeno y quienes al
arrojo valencia quienes desea un
excelente fin de semana y estaremos de
regreso en siete días
un abrazo cuídense mucho y hasta la
próxima chao